what's up guys it's your boy Mary we're
about to do GS news let's get into it
first up we know the exact time you can
download fallout 4s first expansion
utama tron but more importantly they
released an image of a robot that has a
saw blade for a bud kiss my shiny metal
saw blade ask you'll tell people on
march twenty second when Bethesda Game
Studios unlocks at Omicron for xbox one
playstation 4 and pc here are the times
on the Xbox one you get it at midnight
Eastern on ps4 you get it midnight
locally Europe time by 1 p.m. eastern
and on PC you get it midnight Eastern
that's good news at Omicron is included
with the fifty-dollar fallout 4 DLC pass
or it can be purchased by itself for ten
bucks the expansion centers on the
character called the mechanist who has
unleashed a horde of malevolent robots
into the Commonwealth players will be
able to hunt down robots and harvest
their parts to build their own custom
robot companions ie saw blade but Apple
announced this morning a new iphone and
a new iPad and we have exclusive footage
check out the phone in action modeled
here by Derek Zoolander as expected the
device just keeps getting smaller it's a
4-inch phone that apple says is the most
powerful one ever it covers the same cpu
and GPU performance as the iphone 6s
it's capable of capturing 4k video and
features touch ID and Apple pay there
are 16 gig and 64 gig variations of the
phone priced at 40 bucks and 500 bucks
respectively that phone launches on the
thirty-first I don't know if you guys
know this but ipad sales have been on
the decline so in an attempt to turn
things around Apple announced a brand
new smaller iPad hopefully that works
out for them current iPad pros are 12
point 9 inches this baby is only nine
point seven hot damn apple says it's
large enough to get the job done but
small enough to carry share it as Apple
if you want to get in on that hot
division loot cave you better get on it
because they're patching it and they're
killing the cave Ubisoft detailed the
one point zero point two patch coming to
the division this week and it fixes a
number of bugs and tweaks most notably
it
matches the destiny ask Luke cave this
allowed players to repeatedly kill a
particular named enemy in a short span
of time in order to farm item drops from
him the patch makes it so these npcs
don't respond when they're killed
following its removal from a different
patch trained talent is back it's been
changed though previously it allowed for
players to use their signature skills
way more frequently than intended now
it's only available on shotguns marksman
rifles and pistols on Midas SMGs both
new and existing ones being replaced
with responsive talent increasing damage
as you get closer to the target on the
dark zone side you can now fast travel
to the checkpoints but only if you
aren't already inside for the hardcore
players here's what you need to know
there's also improved dark zone chefs
ranked 30 chest will now drop superior
purple items instead of specialized blue
key chests now also have the chance to
drop high-end gold items and that's all
the news there is today but you're stuck
with me all week so I'll see you again
tomorrow
you